[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily we're
now in verdict watch in the death of a
mod arbory trial you can't claim
self-defense
if you are the unjustified initial
aggressor we place roddy bryant's fate
in your hands
we ask you to return a verdict of not
guilty on all counts mike o'brien is in
georgia with the latest from the
courthouse and the family attorney for
brian laundry reveals his cause of death
more than a month after his remains are
found in a florida reserve plus new
details in a deadly waukesha holiday
parade crash why the driver was released
from jail just days before the attack
and later this is something that
i wish never would have happened
but it did and we can't change that kyle
rain has his first interview after his
not guilty verdict in kenosha law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we're now in verdict watch in the
death of a mod arbory trial on tuesday
the prosecution presented its rebuttal
closing argument after defense attorneys
argued on behalf of father and son
travis and gregory mcmichael and william
roddy bryant all three faced charges of
malice murder and felony murder in the
death of 25 year old ahmad arbury travis
michael shot and killed aubry in
february of 2020 as he was jogging near
his brunswick georgia home mig michael
and his father tailed aubry in a pickup
truck and brian followed in a separate
truck he recorded the shooting on video
traveling michael claimed self-defense
and citizens arrest a law that has since
been repealed and replaced on monday
gregory mcmichael's defense attorney
presented closing arguments saying aubry
was not an innocent victim
turning ahmad arbory into a victim
after the choices that he made
does not reflect the reality
of what brought ahmad arbury to satilla
shores
in his khaki shorts
with no socks
to cover his long
dirty toenails
ahmad arbory was not an innocent victim
plundering through larry english's house
on february 23rd
just as he wasn't an innocent victim
all the other nights
like october 25th
or november 18th
or december 15th or february 11th
is he the person responsible for
stealing larry english's expensive boat
equipment i don't know
we don't know
no one investigated that
but can anyone reasonably
believe
that a mod arbory was just
doing a lookie-loo
on those nights
for his part brian's attorney argued his
client could have stopped couldn't have
stopped the shooting and pleaded with
the jury to send him home
from mr brian's perspective when did
roddy brian know
the mcmichaels brought guns
i would submit to you that mr bryan
doesn't know that there's a gun
until it goes off
not because it wasn't there but you see
what mr o'brien is seeing
when did roddy ryan know
travis would shoot mr arbor
i would submit to you he can't know
until mr arbory is actually shot
and
at that point
what could roddy brian do to stop this
tragic shooting
in its rebuttal the prosecution
disagreed arguing brian played a large
role in aubry's death prosecutor linda
donakowski also said that mcmichaels
should not have had a right to claim
self-defense
mr bryan played a substantial and
necessary part in causing his death he
is responsible for the murder
of a mod artery one can use lethal force
in self-defense but only under certain
circumstances
you can't claim self-defense
if you are the unjustified initial
aggressor meaning if you started it
who started this
wasn't a mod artery
if you're committing a felony against
that person
once again we're back to our convenience
store armed robber
he doesn't get
to defend himself against the clerk he's
robbing
he does get a kind of self-defense he's
committing a felony
in this case they committed four
different felonies
including the aggravated assault with a
shotgun
they started it they do not get to claim
self-defense
with that we move into verdict watch our
own michael bryan is outside the glen
county courthouse now and michael what
can you tell us about the jury's
deliberation
hey brian yeah well here we are now into
the sixth hour of deliberation not a
peep i believe that's the legal word not
a peep from this jury no questions no
ask for uh read back or video
so at this point that we just assume
they're busy working at it i would
expect that we will hear soon from the
court as to what the plan is for the
evening if they are close to a decision
perhaps the court would allow them to
move on into the night and maybe come to
a conclusion if not back at it tomorrow
morning and the court's been very
flexible in allowing them to do what
they want to do if they want to come
back
friday they can if not having reached a
verdict by then or saturday so that's
where that stands we have learned though
that now the fbi is involved in the
number of agencies protecting this
community and and planning for
post-verdict security so now you have
the fbi the gbi which is the georgia
bureau of investigation the local
sheriff's office local pd
a lot of folks are involved they're
preparing hopefully won't need what
they're preparing for but the fbi again
now involved with all agencies in
keeping this thing safe
all right michael thank you for the
update of course we're hoping that
everyone stays safe
joining us today is retired detective
and swat officer lisa lockwood and terry
austin
lisa three sets of defense attorneys and
a prosecutor have laid out reasonable
and probable suspicion for citizens
arrest do you see a citizen's arrest
here
i don't because the criteria was not met
regarding seeing an actual crime in
progress they had information that they
believed they saw him on camera travis
said he saw him go into the building at
one point and thought he had a gun a gun
was inferred but we don't have a direct
match up just because you see somebody
or you saw video footage and to make an
assumption a while later that this is
the same individual there was still no
crime if anything it was trespassing and
i don't i'm not even sure if they
brought up the fact that there's a house
under construction with no locks free
access and if there are no signs saying
no ain't no trespassing is every right
to be there and if he was there and
there were signs there then it's a
misdemeanor and the fact is in this
particular case they were pursuing
somebody who they believed did something
absolutely no terry the case has been
given to the jury and as michael said
they can decide to deliberate late on
wednesday or even on saturday can you
guess when we may get a verdict in this
case
i actually think we might get a verdict
before the holiday the jury is working
very hard they work through lunch today
and as we understand they were really
very motivated and anxious to get the
case to get the evidence to start their
deliberations and they're showing some
very serious signs the fact that they
work through lunch means we want to get
this done and there's a lot of evidence
they have all of the videos to look
through and they're going to do that
methodically i believe and don't forget
of course there are nine counts three
defendants so they have to get through
all of those counts to make a correct
determination about each of the
defendants so i expect they'll do that i
expect they'll stay late and i do think
they want to get out before the holiday
which means wednesday night yeah i can't
imagine they want to come back on friday
with a stomach full of turkey when they
can be uh shopping for black friday
michael what was the reaction outside
the court when the case was given to the
jury
you know i think it was a little bit of
relief
you know because the closing arguments
uh stretched into what was two days then
there were the instructions and then the
real work began by this jury so a little
bit of relief a little bit of anxiety
there is a prayer vigil at about 5 30
tonight here in the
square just outside the courthouse so uh
it is described as a non-denominational
just to help everybody heal and get
through this very difficult process as
the jury continues to deliberate
well thank you michael keep up with the
great reporting and stay safe while
you're out there
still ahead on law and crime daily the
deadly waukesha parade crash we take a
closer look at the driver's past
criminal record but first more than a
month after his remains were discovered
we now know brian laundry's cause of
death when the laundry family attorney
told law and crime network after the
break
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charged will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
brian laundry's cause of death revealed
to be suicide by gunshot wound to the
head the laundry family attorney
confirmed the news to law and crime
daily on tuesday
in a statement steve berlino said quote
chris and roberto laundry have been
informed that the cause of death was a
gunshot wound to the head and the manner
of death was suicide chris and roberta
is still mourning the loss of their son
and are hopeful that these findings
bring closures to both families
this revelation comes months after
laundry and fiance gabby potito
separately went missing potato's case
took the nation by storm after she was
reported missing on september 11th ahead
of that petito was last seen alive in
late august near yellowstone national
park while on a road trip with laundry
laundry returned to his family home in
florida at the start of september just
days after petito went missing laundry's
disappearance sparked a nationwide
manhunt for the missing fugitive
potito's body was found near yellowstone
in mid-september her cause of death was
ruled to be a homicide by strangulation
in late october laundry's remains were
found in a florida reserve where he told
family members he went hiking the area
had been covered in water for some time
making the cause of death difficult to
determine his remains were later sent to
an anthropologist for further
examination
let's bring back retired swat officer
and detective lisa lockwood and terry
austin lisa as a retired detective what
are you focused on when you see the
medical exam in determining laundry's
final moments
so we're going to look at the path now
that we know it was a gunshot wound
we're going to look at the direction the
actual exit wound entry wound was the
shot from the bottom of the mandible was
it in the mouth was the exit out the
back of the skull right side to left
side usually is done in the temple to
guarantee that you die with most suicide
victims and was he right-handed or
left-handed so all of that is going to
preclude somebody actually murdering him
out there and it is going to be the path
of travel of the bullet how many wounds
how many bullets
and we have our answer so i believe
that's why we know it was suicide
interesting thank you for breaking that
down lisa now terry it seems like the
story of gabby potato and brian laundry
is all but done is this how you thought
the story would have ended
brian this is not how i thought the
story would end there were many people
who were speculating that he committed
suicide i did not think he would do that
i thought he was trying to escape
remember gabby petito's body was found
on september 19th and there's no
question that most of the evidence is
pointing to the fact that he is
responsible he's the last person to be
seen with her and the fact that he
disappeared is a consciousness of guilt
and that he was trying to escape
prosecution for the potential murder of
gabby petito so
i kind of think that or i thought that
his parents had helped him and that had
he escaped but now that we have found
his body and that it was suicide clearly
he uh you know decided to take that
route
interesting yep we have all the facts
there and that's the seems to be the end
of the gabby potato and brian laundry
saga thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily kyle rinhaus sits down for
his first interview just days after his
acquittal in the kenosha shootings plus
fallout from the deadly waukesha holiday
parade crash why wisconsin officials say
the driver's bond was inappropriately
low
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
milwaukee county district attorney says
bail was inappropriately low for the man
officials say rammed his suv into a
holiday parade in waukesha wisconsin 39
year old daryl brooks faces five counts
of first-degree intentional homicide
after crashing his vehicle into the
parade on sunday five people were killed
and more than 40 others injured
at the time brooks was driving away from
a domestic disturbance incident all this
comes just five days after brooks was
released from the waukesha county jail
with no charges this comes after he
posted a one thousand dollar bail
several weeks prior in a case where
officials say he ran over the mother of
his child at a gas station before that
he was accused of shooting his nephew in
july of 2020 but scheduling conflicts
preventing his right to a speedy trial
his bail is reduced to 500 in that case
the milwaukee county district attorney's
office says an internal review is now
being conducted on the decision to lower
bail to a thousand dollars
back to break down this tragedy's
retired swat officer and detective lisa
lockwood and terry austin lisa brooks
being released on low bail the charges
he was facing has created an argument
that the prosecution failed in reducing
the bail could these deaths have been
avoided
100 percent yes we have somebody who is
a violent offender who has already had a
charge regarding striking the the mother
of his child with his vehicle she was
hospitalized for it only stayed in jail
for nine days and then was released on a
thousand dollar bond and now later on we
find out right before the parade plow
through that he was actually involved in
a domestic incident with a knife so a
lot of this could have been avoided
violent offenders
need to stay behind bars as their cases
go through or offer a very high bond
amount to make sure that people are
protected and i think this could have
been avoided
now terry the da's office is being
audited after this death it seems that
brooks speedy trial right was what
caused the reduction in bail do you
think this could be a reason the d.a
could or should step down
well it depends on the results of that
audit clearly if it finds out that the
d.a is responsible
clearly he could have to step down just
to you know save the whole department
you know the fact is there were two
incidents prior to this christmas parade
incident where the bail was extremely
low where he attacked his ex-wife with
the car where he attacked his nephew
those are violent crimes like lisa said
and with those types of crimes your bail
should not be a thousand dollars or 500
and you should be able to have a speedy
trial so hopefully the audit will show
some results and show some improvement
in what's going on in the da's office
all right as that audit and the
investigation into this case continues
we'll make sure to give you those
updates here on lawn crime daily when we
come back more news out of wisconsin
with kyle rinhaus's first interview post
acquittal what the 18 year old says his
plans are now that he is free of all
charges
welcome back kyle rainhouse is speaking
out for his first interview since his
acquittal angel libya is here with what
rin house has to say anjanet
brian this was an interview with tucker
carlson of fox news and fox news's
opinion hosts were incredibly supportive
of kyle rittenhouse throughout his trial
now this interview took place over the
weekend and it will be part of a longer
documentary produced by tucker carlson
rittenhouse recounted why he says he
went to kenosha that night in august of
2020 and what happened leading up to his
shooting three men killing two of them
rittenhouse said even though he seems
calm he says he is freaking out inside
he also said he feels he's been defamed
by several people his mother singled out
then presidential candidate joe biden
i don't think i would be able to go out
and get a job
and not have to deal with harassment but
i'm at a place now to where
i have to have
people with me because people want to
kill me just because i defended myself
and they're
they're too ignorant to look at the
facts of what happened
now written house said that he wants to
continue studying nursing at arizona
state university and possibly study law
get that he said he also wants to live a
quiet normal life and will likely move
away from the midwest brian
thanks angenet lisa your reaction to
ringhouse's words after being
acquitted uh just incredible i mean i as
far as the interview went i think the
thing that stood out most to me was when
he made the assertion that listen i
support blm i am not racist there was
nothing found in his background to
attach him to any type of racially
motivated right-wing groups and when he
made the statement he didn't think the
trial was so much about him it was more
about the law and procedure of
self-defense being on trial very very uh
great distinction yeah i heard that as
well and agreed great distinction in
that terry acquitted in a court of law
but probably still on trial in the court
of public opinion what do you think is
next for rittenhouse
well it looks like with that recent
appearance on tucker caulston he is
definitely trying to elevate his profile
he's creating a brand he's supported by
social media and he wants to be this
sort of peaceful hero where he's helping
people he's going to be a nurse he's
going to go into medicine but he still
wants to carry a gun and protect second
amendment rights so it's sort of this
dichotomy between helping people and
hurting people hey maybe politics is in
his future as well you never know
internet what did kyle reynolds have to
say about politics
you know he said that he was upset that
his case had been uh you know so
polarized and so politicized not only by
those on the left but also on the right
so he didn't really go into what his
politics may be
but he certainly said that he felt that
it had been used by people on both sides
of the political spectrum and he also
talked about lawyers who used to
represent him allen wood who we all know
and john pierce and he said basically
they were using him to raise money and
using him to further an agenda and
you'll recall that trip to florida where
he appeared in a bar with members of the
proud boys and after that happened his
mother actually fired john pierce as his
lawyer mark richards told us last week
he had told kyle rittenhouse at that
time if that ever happened again he
would no longer be a part of his defense
team brian thanks angela it's going to
be interesting to see how that plays out
because the raising of funds for clients
case that is a very precarious situation
for many defense attorneys so maybe kylo
ren house this is not the last we're
going to hear about him maybe we're not
going to hear about him as a defendant
in a criminal case defending himself
maybe we're going to hear about these
lawyers maybe
this is going to be a case where we
start to hear that these lawyers misuse
this 18 year old to raise money for
their own issues of course if we hear
about that we'll be here law and crime
daily as that unfolds terry lisa and
janette thank you as always and of
course to our viewers thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we will see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you